hello everyone this amazing game was
played in the tenth European individual
championship it was played in 2009 and
vasilia Scott rawness is playing against
Sergey Grigoryants and the well
Grigoryants was the under 14 European
champion and no sorry he was the under
14 world champion in 1997 and in 1999 he
was the under 16 European champion and
well mister Catania's he's a 1 own Greek
Grandmaster he's also a chess order and
well he was 10 times a Greece champion
and were also in 2014 he ran for the
European Parliament he was a candidate
so let's see this brilliant game played
by mr. Petronius who is playing with the
white pieces we have E 4 C 5 so the
sicilian defence Knight to f3 we have e
6 d 4c captures and e4 Knight captures
a6 the con variation we have Knight to
c3 g6 Bishop to e3 and b5 and here mr.
Cutrone yes immediately goes for G for
Bishop to b7 is played and Bishop to g2
we have nice to b7 g5 nice to e 7 and
now white castles he doesn't mind at
this point is already on g5 so his King
his King is kind of well drafty but this
is this is actually okay for white we
have B for attacking this knight on c3
we have Knight to a4 and now d5 and well
we have f4 here so Queen to e5 Queen to
a5 and now c3 now this Queen is
protecting the knight and a four we have
D captures on e4 and C captures on
before would an attack on the Queen and
Queen captures on b4 and here f5 and
okay white give up some material to gain
the initiative I mean the black king is
still waiting there on eh to be to be
attacked we are nice to d5 and well okay
now this Knight is attacking the bishop
on e3 the bishop country on e3 is
undefended and white plays FK
just on e6 he's given up this dark
square bishop but it would be pretty
dangerous to capture it so probably best
move here is simply f captures on e6 but
you know it's hard to resist a nice a
nice Bishop on e3 so mister Grigoryants
captures it he plays Knight captures on
e3 and well here's what happens
mr. Petronius goes he captures on b7
this is what to check and well this pawn
cannot be captured by the King but the
reason it can be captured is actually a
very subtle one the the line if the
point is captured is well it's beautiful
if King captures on b7 then the the best
move for white is actually a three and
this is the move to find and now we have
Knight captures and e1 we have a capture
screen on b4 we have night to e3 and now
rook captures on f7 Bishop to e7
blocking and well here you have a knight
to c5 with check checking the King and
also attacking the bishop here on b7 so
if the King goes to help to help out
this Bishop on b7 white will just grab
this Bishop on e7 so King to e8 and now
simply rook captures on e7 would you
check giving up a rook for two bishops
King captures only 7/9 captures on b7
and I'll Knight captures g2 King
captures on g2 and with two nights for a
rook white is white is doing great here
so after this he captures on d7 would
check gregorian's saudis a3 idea and he
played King to d8 and here we have rook
captures on f7
and you you're at probably asking what
is this I mean your queen is hanging on
d1 but not really if you capture the
Queen you get nice to e6 and this is
checkmate in one move so after this rook
the f7 idea the Queen cannot be captured
we have a bishop to d5 now attacking the
rook on f7 and here well white again the
deploys the idea of a3 now attacking the
Queen and well again you can't capture
the Queen if knife capture sandy one now
simply a capture some before if Bishop
captures rook on f7 you get capture
sandy one
and well this is this is much better for
white the idea is that a king the King
still can't capture this pawn on d7
because of United to b6 with Czech
winning the rook so after a three Queen
to a5 is played and now white plays a
move that is that is extremely evil he
plays Queen to b3 now trying to give up
the Queen with Bishop captures on b3
but again this is unplayable if Bishop
captures on b3 then Knight to c6 with
check and this is checking the King and
also forking the Queen and i-5
but after Queen King to c7 of course not
capturing the Queen but playing upon 2 D
8 promoting to a queen sorry and after
King captures knight on c6 simply Queen
to d7 and this is checkmate
so very nice move this Queen to b3 this
is my probably my favorite move of this
game so we have Bishop to d6 and here
what simply captures the knight on e3
Queen captures only 3 and we have Queen
captures knight on a 4 so now Knight the
e6 with Czech and this comes with a very
nice idea of better captures on e6 and
Queen to b6 check and well the King has
no squares only move is to block with
this dark squared Bishop Bishop to c7
and now Queen captures on e6 and here
well black is definitely not feeling
very comfortable black has to bring the
Queen to help out with the defense so
Queen to d4 would check King to h1 and
now Queen to e5 offering the exchange of
Queens but of course the black king is
still in b8 there is a very nice white
pawn and d7 white isn't interested in
trading Queens so Queen to h3 is played
rook to b8 getting the rook out of this
bishops path and now rook a to f1
doubling up rooks and the F file and
with some nasty ideas of rook to f8
check so black black stops this of
course Bishop to d6 stopping rook a fate
and well here the best move is actually
rook to see one with with the threat of
rook to c8
but mister Petronius finds then if it
finds a very interesting idea he plays
g6 and in this position
his opponent mr. Grigoryants resigned
the game as well he doesn't really have
a move here for
you can't capture the pawn because
you'll lose a rook on h8 and well if
something like h6 is played then now
route the c1 and although roof to c1 was
playable it's it's kind of a nicer line
after this g6 idea so you don't have to
stop with rook to c8 it would check so
Bishop to C 7 for example but now rook
captures on c7 and this is completely
lost for black and now you can see the
idea of this beautiful g6 move because
if Queen captures on c7 well now yet
Queen to h4 with checkmate so very nice
idea this g6 move so after rook captures
on c7 probably the king has the capture
of rooks King captures rook on c7 and
now upon to d8 promoting to a queen and
this comes with a check from the Queen
and the rook on f7 you can't really
capture the Queen if you capture the
Queen you get Queen to d7 checkmate so
here I don't know probably moving the
king somewhere but you're already down a
piece this is well this is unplayable
for black so after this very nice pawn
to g6 bush Sergei gregorian's resigned
at the game so yeah I think this was a
very nice example of how to play how to
play a beautiful chess and that Bishop
to b3 moved that is that is some move
huh
so yeah I would like to thank mr. Edwin
Park Fernando Assad to Ramallah and Tony
more guitar for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here and if you're
a new subscriber to this channel I will
also put a link in the description below
with a playlist of all of my previous
uploads so I thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon